welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast my name is eric trexler i am the
special special temporary primary host i
think i got that right correct
yeah union's okay with that sure perfect
uh today i am joined by greg
he is currently the permanent guest
co-host for now and a prominent leader
in the uh what's the name of your union
again the stronger by science podcast
co-host union correct yeah and and i
assume you do great work with that
organization who i'm on very good terms
with
um we've got a lot to cover in today's
show before we get to that uh if you
enjoy the show and you would like to
support it there are many ways that you
could do that
you could like rate or subscribe
wherever you happen to get podcasts
you could join our email newsletter you
could do that at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter
you could use our discount code at bulk
supplements if you go to
bulksupplements.com and you use the
discount code sbs pod that'll get you a
five percent discount off your entire
order you could subscribe to the mass
research review that is a monthly
research review that we are co-authors
of or you could check out our diet app
which is called macro factor and it does
offer a free trial
uh so greg how is the road to the stage
road to the stage is going well uh this
past week was a pretty solid week uh hit
a new low uh 227.2
uh
and i'm a pound away from a milestone
i'm very much looking forward to the
two-thirds way point uh along my journey
of this current cut
um
and yeah just just kind of looking back
at the week a big bright spot was that
uh this past week was
the the busy week in my month with mass
writing um and it ended up being far
busier than i anticipated so
uh if you
subscribe to mass just here's a little
peek ahead a slight change in
um
in format is coming so
we're going to start having a cover
story for each issue that
will also be published concurrently on
stronger by science and so i'm doing the
the cover story for this upcoming month
and uh i won't tell you what it is yet
uh i i teased it on instagram a few days
ago but if you missed it it was a story
and they are fleeting and ethereal by
nature so uh you'll find out june 1st
otherwise but anyway um the
the the work
required to
get to the point that i could start
writing um
ended up being a lot more than i
anticipated so a
a busy week turned into
uh a weak border-ish bordering on
hellish uh in terms of of a total
workload and previously in situations
like that
i would have a tendency to just kind of
like stress eat to
uh
to numb the stress and and uh just bad
vibes that i'm experiencing and uh i i
did not do that this past week and i've
noticed
over time as this cut has progressed
that that is
a skill that i have have gained and
developed over time where
you know i've i've found uh
other ways of of coping with stress and
making myself feel better um
rather than food so you know i
like not only was was did the last week
go well but it went well
in spite of an obstacle that i think
previously would have tripped me up uh
so yeah i i feel good about that overall
nice yeah like you mentioned it's been a
crazy week very busy in the uh
the cluster of entities associated with
the stronger by science universe and
listeners might wonder is that why eric
stumbled over half the words in the
introduction
i'm not going to answer that i'm gonna
leave that up to interpretation uh but
yes i
theoretically could have gotten more
sleep the last few days would have been
nice but uh but anyway yeah
i think this is gonna be a really nice
issue of mass i think your cover story
turned out great and and there's a lot
of good studies this month yes sir um
now road to athens uh would you even
believe it i don't have any updates i've
barely had an opportunity to step foot
in a gym the last few days but that's
okay uh no steps backward which is good
i like that
uh what about feats of strength
feats of strength so yeah uh last
episode i
mentioned some big gym lifts from
jessica bittner
her competition was this past week and
uh as expected she did very well hit a
new uh unofficial world record for both
the squad and the deadlift in her weight
class that's the uh the 76 kilo class i
believe
so she squatted two 17 and a half kilos
which is uh 479 480 pounds uh and
uh deadlifted 252 and a half kilos which
is like 556 pounds um
so yeah great performance for her looked
like she had more in the tank for
everything um
so you know if if she is pushed at
worlds which
i suspect she might be um like worlds is
coming up
and i expect that her
and uh
uh what's her name from new zealand uh
tongatea
are probably
going to be gearing up for quite the
battle in that weight class um
so yeah we'll we'll see uh what's to
come but uh great performance from her
and uh then let's circle back to julius
maddox world
where we haven't visited in a while but
uh
yeah he he recently hit um
361
kilos or 796 pounds uh
in the gym for for bench press which i
don't need to contextualize that those
are just just nutty numbers uh we're
still we're still waiting for the first
800 pound bench in competition and you
know once again he looks like he's
gearing up for it and i hope he does it
awesome yeah it's
getting ever closer to that 800 number
that uh that everybody's looking forward
to so i'm excited to see that
um all right moving on to the content
for today's episode we've got a couple
coaches corner segments so
uh i feel like you and i have just been
like up to our ears in the research
literature the last few days with what
we're working on so it'll be a nice
little change of pace to uh shift focus
a little bit and be a little bit more
a little bit more practical and applied
for these coaches corner segments of
course they're all informed by research
to some extent but you know not a nitty
gritty research review
so for my coach's corner i want to talk
about a dietary strategy that i've used
it almost kind of has felt like a very
natural default way of eating for me
whenever i'm
cutting or
just trying to kind of passively reduce
calorie intake so
uh for example if i notice that my my
body weight is starting to creep up and
i'm not tracking macros at the time
i might implement this strategy to stop
that upward trajectory or if i'm about
to enter a cutting phase i might
proactively implement this strategy and
there's not a great word for it so
instead i'm just going to use like a
kind of like a mad libs of just buzz
words here uh
i think you could kind of refer to it
loosely as protein-sparing modified
time-restricted feeding uh it sounds
like kind of a nonsense jumble of
buzzwords like i said but
what i am really getting at with this
strategy is the fact that
omad one meal a day uh as an eating
pattern
is getting relatively popular i mean
it's not like huge but there are more
people doing it now than i can ever
recall in the past and doing it
explicitly
as an intentional eating strategy yeah
do doing it intentionally i mean go back
far enough i'm sure there are plenty of
people who are only eating one meal per
day but for for different reasons yeah
but but it's uh
i've never before seen as many people
who say i am
intentionally restricting myself to one
meal a day
as a dietary strategy for fitness
purposes yeah yeah um and i really do
get the draw because if you've ever
experimented with that approach uh
you'll generally find that
you end up doing a lot of very passive
calorie restriction
simply by having such a restrictive
feeding window you know like time
restricted feeding the most common
application is like an eight-hour
feeding window which honestly is not
that tight of a feeding window i mean
that's basically like skip one meal at
the beginning or end of the day and
you're you're in that window like pretty
much no problem
uh but you know some people say well
instead of doing an eight hour feeding
window i'll do six or maybe four and
then one meal a day is as tight as a
feeding window can really get unless
you're doing uh the the high school
buffet style one meal a day where you
show up to the buffet spend your eight
dollars and you just sit down for like
seven or eight hours and and eat until
they kick you out yeah but aside from
that one meal a day you're usually
talking about a feeding window that's
you know 60 90 minutes something like
that or or i mean if you eat fast enough
they might kick you out after like two
hours yeah that is may or may not have
first-hand experience with that yeah
jinjin buffet in mocksville north
carolina you're on notice you
permanently banned me from the lunch
buffet in 2009 and i still have not
forgotten yeah the twin dragon they've
forgotten
they might have next time i'm home i
might roll the dice
the twin dragon was a lot more
accommodating uh back back in my younger
years i mean you you could really
really settle in there for quite some
time before
before you got any attention
but anyway uh one meal a day generally
speaking you're talking about a very
tight feeding window
and it does help with some passive
calorie restriction what i mean by
passive is without being overly
intentional about your food choices you
might find that simply by eating in a
tighter window it's hard to to go too
far beyond whatever your number is you
know twenty four hundred twenty eight
hundred thirty two hundred calories in
that single meal
and another benefit specifically with
the one meal a day approach is uh
depending on your psychological makeup
it could help you keep your mind off of
food throughout the day now
i've definitely seen this completely
backfire and go the opposite direction
where
because you are restricting to one meal
a day
throughout the whole rest of the day all
you're thinking about is damn sucks i
didn't have breakfast man wish i had
lunch so you have to really uh
individualize and think about your
personal experience
if you're going to implement this type
of strategy for me
as someone who's not that food focused
in nature
if i tell myself hey i'm having one meal
a day the rest of the day i just kind of
get busy and forget about it and focus
on other things have some coffee have
some water maybe a diet soda here and
there it's it's really not something
that i think about frequently and recur
recurrently you know throughout the day
um now here's the problem with one meal
a day
is it's really not great for protein
distribution uh generally speaking the
research would indicate
that we would prefer
to get
three or more
large servings of protein throughout the
day so three or more large boluses that
are giving us at least you know 20 30 40
grams of protein a day and with one meal
a day obviously that's not going to be
possible it's not going to be a you know
feasible goal to try to make both of
those things work
and that also with one meal a day can
put you in a somewhat challenging
position where you have to say well do i
want to have uh
you know pre-exercise
protein or post-exercise protein you
don't get the ability to have pre and
post and along those lines
you have to to try to make some
difficult decisions of like do i want to
go into this workout totally fueled but
also not overly full and then how do i
have a post-workout recovery meal it can
become very logistically challenging to
figure out this one huge meal a day you
know it can't go right before your
workout but if it goes really far before
your workout you have no peri workout
nutrition at all
so it can get a little bit challenging
logistically so what i like to do
is implement a strategy and like i said
it's certainly not for everybody but i
like to implement a strategy that in my
opinion kind of gets me the best of both
worlds and so what i do is i will
basically do like a protein sparing
modified fast until dinner and what that
means is my earlier meals
are structured
in an extremely protein focused way so
it's either going to be you know
almost all protein you know protein
shake something like that or it'll be a
meal that is just a very lean protein
with some fibrous vegetables right so
maybe you have like
uh
an omelette with mostly egg whites very
minimal fat one or zero yolks and a
bunch of vegetables in there so all my
meals going up toward dinner are going
to be almost exclusively protein and
maybe some fibrous vegetables in the mix
you might get some trace carbs and fat
you know outside of that but generally
speaking we're talking about lean
protein and maybe some fibrous
vegetables uh and so i'll have maybe a
breakfast like that maybe a lunch like
that and then my dinner ultimately
becomes my my true meal for the day
right and that's where i have starches
sugars more fat content so it's not an
extreme macronutrient distribution when
you look at the entire day in aggregate
it's just those first couple meals where
i'm basically saying i'm doing one meal
a day
and just strategically supplementing
some protein servings earlier in the day
and of course you could invert that if
you wanted to you could wake up have a
really big meal and then just have a
couple targeted protein servings later
in the day but i personally like to uh
to have dinner as my meal because
psychologically that helps me out a lot
whenever i'm tracking
closely with my meals and uh my calorie
intake is a little bit low i find that
psychologically i really dislike
situations where i notice early in a day
like you're running out of calories like
to me it's psychologically very uh very
comforting to know
that i've got this sizable dinner that's
coming later in the day which almost
certainly will hold me over till bedtime
so generally speaking you know it looks
like one meal a day when it comes to
that big dinner meal that i like but i
am putting those protein boluses earlier
in the day so that i have a little bit
of the best of both worlds like those
little protein servings don't really
feel like a meal it's just get it in and
move on with your day not focus on food
the whole time for me it strikes a nice
balance here um and i do this flexibly
you know so
uh let's say that i've got a really big
workout and it's occurring before my
dinner you know
or or i'm just hungry for the gym right
or hungry before the gym so hungry for
the gym
and before the iron baby exactly but you
know you've got a big workout coming up
you're feeling a little bit low on
energy kind of hungry research would
indicate that you probably don't want to
go into a big workout feeling hunger
it there's some research indicating that
hunger as a sensation itself could
impair performance in resistance
training sessions uh so i don't do this
with a super
rigid focus right so i might have a
couple protein boluses early in the day
and say you know what before this
workout
i'm gonna have some extra carbs and fat
like a little snack rather than a full
meal i'll go into my workout properly
fueled feeling great and then have my
big dinner afterwards so i don't do this
in a really restrictive or strict wet
strict way
but in my experience this has been a
really helpful way to kind of find that
middle ground where i'm able to cut down
on some of the mindless snacking
throughout the day which is something
that can really catch up with me
personally uh i'm less focused on food
throughout the day because i'm just kind
of treating it like these little
strategic protein feedings rather than
sitting down and enjoying an entire meal
uh it does tend to be really time
efficient so like my breakfast and lunch
and sometimes will just be a protein
shake like a ready to drink beverage
which is i mean extremely time efficient
uh and yeah i get an opportunity to to
enjoy a large meal in the evening that
might
theoretically take more preparation time
it's kind of my my meal for the day
where i have to actually put time and
effort and focus into cooking and
enjoying all those different foods and
things like that and i don't have to
stress out about running out of calories
super early in the day
or getting to a point where i went a
little overboard with my breakfast and
then the whole rest of the day i'm
thinking about restricting and
restricting and restricting so
what's really nice about this strategy
is you do not necessarily need to
deviate from
best practices in terms of protein
feedings in order to get some of these
upsides of that one meal a day approach
now the only thing that you're kind of
missing out of the
purported or perceived benefits of one
meal a day is some people really push
that idea that like oh you gotta fast 22
hours a day so that your autophagy is
off the charts and you're you know all
this other stuff and i i simply don't
subscribe to that set of ideas i i don't
think that they're based on strong
evidence
so
from my perspective you're getting the
the most evidence supported potential
benefits of one meal a day without
sacrificing the obvious downsides when
it comes to peri workout nutrition and
protein feedings have you ever tried
something like that
i have and and i was actually going to
comment uh
do you know who john kiefer is or was
was he big when you were
just like all up in grad school and not
paying attention just car back loading
right yeah yeah that's that's what this
reminded me of a lot
um
and i'm not saying that to to tar your
good name yeah um i no like i i always
thought like oh yeah this seems like a a
practically useful strategy and where
where kiefer went astray was being like
yeah like this is basically magic uh
right it will make it impossible for you
to store fat due to
some reasons that you know i as a as a
physicist understand but you you plebs
never could
um
so yeah i i think that uh
it's it's a very
valid practical strategy that
maybe has previously been oversold
uh
by other people but that that doesn't
mean that it doesn't have utility yeah
and again i i'm certain a hundred
percent certain that there are a lot of
people who would not
respond super favorably to this like
i
have never explicitly like
i wouldn't say never but only in rare
circumstances do i even bring this up
with clients i much prefer to make
adjustments based on their pre-existing
eating behaviors and only when we run
into
a series of obstacles where this seems
to be potentially a useful solution only
then do i bring this out it's not like
day one enrollment materials for my
coaching services it's like hey guess
what you're on the trexler eating method
and this is what it is yeah and even i
don't use this all that often like i
said it's kind of strategically
implemented
in some very specific circumstances but
i would suggest that it has no
physiological benefit uh compared to a
traditional eating pattern
but i would suggest that there are
physiological benefits if you compare a
strict one meal a day strategy versus
this kind of modified approach
and one of the reasons i mentioned this
i forgot to uh to bring this up but
i reviewed a study that was looking at
one meal a day in a fairly recent issue
of mass and it was a very short-term
study so it's not like you'd say wow
they lost six kilograms of fat-free mass
because like you can only lose so much
in like a couple weeks you know i forget
it was like a one or two week study
timeline
so
the body comp numbers you couldn't do
much with them but a lot of the data
within that particular paper were
leaning toward some of the intuitive
downsides that you would expect from
such a disadvantageous uh protein
feeding strategy so yeah i would suggest
this is physiologically of of no benefit
relative to a standard uh feeding
window or a standard uh
kind of dietary schedule in terms of
meal timing uh but i do think uh that
there's considerable benefit when you
compare it to
strict one meal a day eating yeah
you know i do um
i do something similar to that from time
to time but generally just with
either carbs or fat
uh just kind of depending on what i'm
hankering for when i'm meal prepping um
you know sometimes i'll make a big batch
of meal prep food that has macro splits
that are
roughly the macro splits i'm aiming for
for the day and then i just eat on that
throughout the day but sometimes i just
feel like making higher fat meal prep
food and so i'll eat that earlier in the
day and then mostly just eat protein and
carbs at night or if i want to make a
higher carb batch of meal prep i just
eat that earlier in the day and then
mostly protein and fat at night um
so it's it's kind of the opposite like
you know i eat what i want to eat
earlier in the day and then just kind of
compensate for it later
and generally it's not
all protein meals and then protein carbs
fat meals it's generally
you know
protein and carbs earlier in the day in
protein and fat later at night or vice
versa um you know not not driven by
uh any
any assumption that that's
physiologically preferable it's just
like yeah trying to hit my macros and
then what do i want to make for meal
prep and then you know just just work
everything else around that um
yeah i've i found that to be a pretty
practical approach for me as well yeah
and a really important thing the last
thing i'll mention here is that the
underlying psychological processes going
on
are important you know so like if i were
going throughout the day saying you know
i only eat you know mostly protein at
breakfast and lunch because actually if
you eat carbs at for breakfast you store
a lot of fat and you get diabetes yeah
or you know oh i can't eat fat until one
meal a day because i'll get like heart
disease like
it's not uh there there is no underlying
carb or fat phobia that's baked into
this strategy it's simply just like you
know what if i sit down for a whole meal
here i might you know
you know it'll disrupt me from my
workflow take me out of my day and i
might end up eating you know maybe two
or three hundred calories more than i
really need to just kind of get my
protein in and feel satiated and move on
with my day so it's really just a matter
of uh time efficiency uh and just
finding a way to get that protein and
without
feeling like i'm going to be snacking on
something for the next 90 minutes so
it's purely behavioral but it's
important if if you think that this is
going to draw you into some of those um
potentially problematic psychological
processes then just leave it it's not
for you you know you got to find an
eating pattern that that is completely
compatible with
your goals but also kind of your
psychological makeup
uh so what's your coach's corner about
yeah so uh mine is
uh inspired by a conversation i had
yesterday um
with someone who said like yeah i've
been i've been working out a lot more
recently um
you know i i'm
not as young as i once was and now like
one of the issues i'm running into is
when i
start like an arm workout uh you know go
right into kind of hypertrophy rep
ranges for tricep work and man my my
elbows just really don't like that used
to be fine now
you know it's it's just it's just
creakier than it used to be um
and so i i gave him some advice and uh i
was like ah this would be decent podcast
content so this is roughly a coach's
corner about
about keeping your joints happy if
you're
a creaky boomer like myself and some of
your joints don't like you as much as
they once did
so
to be clear i'm not making any claims
about
injury risk rehabilitation
anything like that it's just purely you
know what might give you
slightly more
pleasurable perceptual sensations during
a training session um if you have
you know joints that that you might um
colloquially describe
as as achy or creaky so this isn't about
like oh i have an acute muscle strain
how do i train for that i have uh
a chronic like tendinopathy issue how do
i train around that so you know we're
not talking about any of that stuff just
ah whatever like my knees are generally
fine but they you know if i squat heavy
in a workout they don't like that much
so like what do i do so you know that's
that's what we're talking about here and
i will admit uh i
at least in part uh learned this
approach from john meadows um
and uh
first first of all rest in peace uh
you know he he was i think
he was one of my biggest inspirations
for just kind of
i would say just like practical training
tips like there there are there are a
lot of people out there in the world who
offer
uh one weird trick for x y and z in the
gym and i i try to keep pretty
open-minded and if i see something even
if i think it looks dumb if it looks fun
i'll try it
and i gotta say a lot of those one weird
tricks that people throw out uh seem to
have a very poor signal to noise ratio
like
it's something that's
unique just for the sake of being unique
but doesn't really seem to to do what
it's supposed to doesn't really seem to
work that well uh but i would recommend
looking back through john meadows's
content i think his one weird tricks
that he threw out did have a very
excellent signal to noise ratio he'd be
like yeah just like
try this this weird uh series of
exercises or like particular exercise
for your lats like i promise it's gonna
blow him up and i'd be like
john that looks
no but then i try it i'd be like god
damn it john you're a genius
so anyway i i cribbed this in part from
him um
because you know uh he
he's spent a lot of his time kind of in
the public eye of the fitness industry
uh in his in his 40s and later um you
know so his his joints weren't as young
as they previously had been but one of
the hallmarks of of his training
approach like if you'd watch a lot of
his training videos is he would train
heavy and he would train really hard and
so one of the things he was trying to
accomplish is like how can i do that
while keeping my joints as happy with me
as as they can be um and so the strategy
he came up with which is very simple uh
but in my experience works really well
is whatever
whatever joint you're about to train the
muscles around
um that generally doesn't like you
just start with a
i don't know the best wording for this
but just kind of like a non-stressful
pump type exercise so
it's not something that's going to take
you through
any sort of like extreme stretch it's
not going to take
you know any of your tissues close to
their tensile limits
and you're just going to do high reps
with it and importantly i don't know why
this matters but it seems to matter you
want to do it for both sides of the
joint so for example if you were going
to do some some triceps training you'd
want to do something for your triceps
but also your biceps just to kind of
warm up everything around your elbow
joint and when i say kind of like a
non-stressful type lift uh you wouldn't
want to do skull crushers where you're
you know taking your elbows into full
flexion under heavy load um you know
nothing like that so you know it might
be something like rope push downs um
and you know you're just gonna start
with
uh a couple sets or even just one set of
20 30 reps relatively close to failure
of a triceps exercise
uh repeat the process with a biceps
exercise and then from there you can
start moving into heavier stuff so you
know that's when you might want to get
into your skull crushers for sets of 8
to 12 or you know really any other
triceps exercise and
don't know why this works but it works
quite well
you know your tendons seem to be happier
your joints seem to be happier
and
one other additional little wrinkle that
i would add to this
is so step one do kind of high rep pump
type work across both sides of the joint
step two just kind of train normally
after that and then step three i think
uh at least i personally experience
dividends from ending my training with
kind of what i would call like a
stretchy type movement um
so you know you you are now looking for
something that is going to take that
joint through a full range of motion
uh and you're generally going to do like
paused reps where you can really kind of
let your muscles like sink into it like
feel a good stretch in the muscle um
and do that to end with so
uh let's see an example of how this
could work is let's say you have creaky
knees so you're gonna start your
like knee dominant lower body training
maybe with just some light knee
extensions and then very important don't
forget
next thing you're going to do is leg
curls warm up your hamstrings as well
and then from there
you know move into your heavier normal
type training and then something to kind
of stretch your quads to end with
one of my go-to's for this is split
squats but generally when you do like
rear leg elevated split squats you're
trying to train the the front leg the
leg that's down so you try to keep most
of your weight shifted forward but to
get a really good stretch in your quads
to end with you want to try to keep a
lot of your weight back so you're you're
keeping a good amount of the weight on
your back leg and for every rep you're
gonna go down you're gonna hold that
bottom position of the rear leg elevated
split squat squeeze the glute on the
back leg try to get your hips forward
stretch out your quads and hip flexors
really well
and then to initiate the drive up you're
going to drive your front heel through
the floor but you're also going to kick
into the bench um so so it's almost like
you're doing a knee extension with your
back leg as you're doing kind of a
squatting pattern with your front leg uh
and you know
uh for for the stretchy movement you end
on you also don't want to you don't want
that to be super heavy like you want you
want it to be something where you can
focus more on the stretch than
am i strong enough just to complete the
reps
um
but yeah that
that approach
um
so the the approach i'm generally
describing probably isn't strictly
speaking ideal for strength so uh you
know powerlifters listening to this
might be might be
hearing me and saying like oh no like if
i
did uh a couple sets of 20 to 30 reps
relatively relatively close to failure
for like a pump type triceps exercise
my bench training that comes after like
i might have to take five ten percent
off my training loads
and like
yeah you probably will uh and that's
that's another you know again for the
purpose of like trying to keep your
joints happy if you can
uh stress all of your target muscles
just as hard
but not have to expose them to quite as
much load
that might be preferable um
so like yeah this is just kind of it's
advice for people who are
trying to stay in the gym trying to
still train hard uh but maybe not
necessarily for the for the sole purpose
of
uh maximizing strength performance at
all costs so like it comes with
trade-offs this is more talking about
kind of just like hypertrophy and
quote unquote like general health type
resistance training um
but yeah uh i i do
my training looks a lot more like this a
lot of the time these days um
especially like uh my like i said my
friend asked me about like a creaky
elbow um like this is how i do all of
all of my my arm and upper body training
now my elbows used to be basically
bulletproof like nothing ever bothered
them and then i broke my arm last year
and ever since then my left elbow just
doesn't like me as much as as it used to
um so yeah i take
an approach very similar to this now uh
and it's
it's been huge for me because like
previously after an upper body training
day like
my left elbow would hurt during training
and it would hurt the day after training
but now
like i i approach my upper body training
this way my elbow does not hurt during
training does not hurt after training uh
it's good stuff so
you know
that's uh that's my little coach's
corner so just to reiterate step one
pump type work both sides of the joint
if you're talking about the elbows
biceps and triceps you're talking about
the hips maybe start with something like
uh body weight or very light hip thrusts
and then also
maybe some leg raises like something for
the hip flexors and the abs
um for the knees you're talking about
both quads and hamstrings like so some
some sort for shoulders uh
or like chest training maybe start with
flies but again you don't want to take
it to an extreme in range of motion so
you know like high rep flies stopping
before you get that stretch and then
maybe if you want to do more stretchy
flies do that at the end of your of your
workout
so you might want to start with both
flies and rear delt raises if you're
talking about warming up your shoulders
for chest training
so that's step one just high high rep
pump training across both sides of the
joint then just train like normal and
then end with some sort of uh kind of
strength exercise that you can that
allows you to really
uh sink into a stretch for whatever
muscle you just trained
to to end your training
to be clear i don't want to make any any
physiological claims about how this is
going to affect the structure or
function of any particular soft tissue
not making any any prehab or rehab
claims or anything like that just
in general if this is a problem you're
you're dealing with tends to feel nice
uh and and training when you feel nice
is good
yeah it's uh
when you start i was googling something
as you were talking because this got me
thinking i was like you know back in the
day uh around 2012 2013 i started doing
hamstring curls before my squats
and i was like i think i might have got
that from john meadows you probably did
and so i was googling it and i did yeah
and i was looking at an article he wrote
about it and in the article he said in
two different spots and this is a short
article i don't know why it works he's i
don't know why it works and i do not
have scientific evidence this is not
science yeah this is [ __ ] i do that
feels good yeah and uh and i think
that's an important thing in like the
whole evidence-based fitness world is
like
it is okay
like it there's nothing wrong with
saying like hey this is like
something that is not dangerous is not
deleterious
it seems to work nice and i don't have
scientific evidence for it
yeah do with that what you will no like
that's something that i've talked about
a lot before like i think um
like i mean the the key for example
earlier in this episode is is a great
example of that like i think a lot of
people get themselves in trouble
because
they are unwilling to have the
intellectual humility to say
like hey this thing seems good like it
uh
it's a practical approach that seems to
work for me and uh you know if you're
having similar problems to the ones i'm
having maybe it's worth you
experimenting with it as well like
that's
that's a perfectly valid thing to say
um
it's a very intellectually honest way to
approach things where there's not a ton
of conclusive evidence one way or the
other or just not any direct research at
all
and i i think people are
are unwilling to do that because
they maybe think it makes them sound
dumb or like less serious or they think
that
people won't take their advice as
seriously unless they
make it seem like everything they say
has a ton of supporting evidence but no
i think it's important to
be able to be honest about
what level of evidence supports the
things you say um and if it is just
purely anecdotal just say this shit's
anecdotal seems nice um
but yeah like the the the carb night
stuff if kiefer just came out and said
like
yeah man like if you're
struggling with like food fixation
through the day and and controlling your
total calorie intake yeah mostly just
eat protein through the day try eating
some carbs at night seems to work pretty
well for me give it a shot i don't think
anyone would have been upset about it
but that was a very controversial
dietary approach
because he went out on a limb and said
like yes like this is going to be
magical for these reasons and it was
just like
completely [ __ ] like massively over
extrapolated like basic physiology stuff
that didn't actually support the claims
he was making and like i feel that i
feel that same way about um
about like paleo stuff like
as far as kind of like popular fad diets
go uh the
the general dietary approach that paleo
folks recommend is perfectly reasonable
it's like yeah you know mostly stick to
unprocessed foods when possible
um
i mean there are so many different
schools of paleo but like that's
basically it um like that's perfectly
reasonable dietary advice but you know
then when they say and this is going to
work the best for performance for health
for everything because like this is what
we evolved to eat and then like more
uh anthropological and paleontolo
paleontological evidence comes out
showing like oh yeah the way you said
paleolithic people ate yeah you're full
of [ __ ] they didn't eat that like then
paleo folks have egg on their face
because it's like oh yeah you said this
thing is good for these reasons
turns out the reasons uh are wrong and
you're an idiot but like the general
advice they're giving is often like
decent advice yeah and if they just
stuck with
the decent advice of like uh you know if
possible eat less processed foods um
well i guess that's not the best example
because there is like direct evidence on
eating less processed foods but like you
you get my point yeah you know just just
be honest about the level of evidence
you have supporting something and in my
case for my coach's corner segment
i don't have evidence other than
feels nice for me seemed like it felt
nice for john meadows uh
maybe it will feel nice for you yeah and
just to reiterate there there's just
like some little qualifiers this whole
approach of like yeah it works for me
i'm gonna go ahead and recommend it to
people like
it's important to accurately present the
amount of support
or lack of support for that idea it's
important that the idea does not have uh
reasonable potential to be harmful or
deleterious right so it's it's very
different to say like hey like you're
probably going to be pretty good in
terms of your dietary goals if you
generally pick stuff from this whole
genre of foods versus like
you know just straight up
orthorexia inducing propaganda
right like the second you deviate from
the paleo foods like you're you're gonna
get sick dude like that's really bad
yeah like so there there's a fine line
between you know it it's gotta be uh
stuff that is
doesn't have potential to be truly
deleterious or harmful
but also like the thing that drives me
nuts about anecdotes that are shared in
this context is again when people
just are unable to say like hey
this is anecdotal like when people take
these anecdotes and then just reach for
the closest science available and say
actually this is evidence-based science
uh that i'm giving you it's like yeah
it's not though so
as long as people are kind of putting
out the right caveats and not
recommending things that are reckless
like this kind of anecdotal stuff
certainly has a place in filling in the
gaps with uh with the way we approach
training and nutrition yeah uh and i
mean i i would say it even goes like
maybe even a step beyond that because
something that i
have observed happening and i'm not
gonna
[Music]
i'm yeah no i don't feel like doing that
i'm not gonna name specific people or
call out like specific concepts where
i've seen this but a
not uncommon dynamic that i see from
time to time is maybe someone does make
an initial claim
[Music]
that they make in a
circumspect and into an intellectually
honest way they say like hey i tried
this thing
worked pretty well for me yeah you know
maybe you give it a shot too if you're
experiencing uh similar things and you
know so the the first iteration of it is
totally good and then you know they have
a reasonably large audience and
um
you know some some portion of those
people uh
try out that piece of advice
and
then you know they
this individual maybe posts about the
same thing again and i'm not i don't
have one specific person in mind like
this is a pattern i've witnessed
multiple times across multiple different
topics but yeah so the the original
poster like post something again like
hey this thing i posted about a couple
weeks ago
still doing it still seems to be pretty
nice for me and then in their comment
section you see
quite a few comments of people in their
audience saying like oh yeah like that's
awesome i tried it too and you were you
were right this is awesome it works so
well and like maybe you see one or two
dissenters but it's like mostly very
positive feedback like yeah dude like
you're you're absolutely on the right
track here that was great advice and
then
over time it kind of morphs from hey i
tried this thing and it felt nice to
i recommended this thing
hundreds of people have tried it and it
seems like almost universally it's
incredible for them so you know there's
there's there's not like a scientific
study on it but look look at all of this
like real world in the trenches evidence
like this thing like it's it's a it's a
sure thing like the the amount of uh
positive stories about this is just
overwhelming at this point
and
i can certainly understand
why someone would go that route uh but i
would i would caution against it if you
dear listener
are ever in this situation
for a couple reasons
one is that um
most of the time
like
even if you don't do this intentionally
like you
you tend to attract people to you
who have similar characteristics to you
so just kind of like by by default if
you recommend something to your audience
your your audience is probably more
similar to you than they would be to a
random sample of the general population
and so something that
maybe say only works for a minority of
people and you being in that minority
people in your audience are probably
also disproportionately likely to be in
that minority so just from the jump
you're not starting with a
representative sample
and two
it's
it can become a thing where
if you talk about something frequently
people
for whom
that thing works well
will tend to gravitate towards you just
uh
you know because people like being told
that they're right about things and
don't like being told that they're wrong
about things so you know if people try
your advice and it doesn't work well for
them
they'll probably just stop following you
over time so you'll get less negative
feedback from them and as other people
try this stuff and uh you know it works
well for them they'll be more likely to
follow you so as you promote an idea
just just kind of through the natural
flow of people through social networks
you will accrue an audience that is even
less representative than it was
previously that's like basically cherry
picked
to make everything you say
sound really good um
and so
yeah like the the
observation that hey i put this out in
the world and it seems to work for a lot
of people
that may be true
but that's still not good evidence that
it
works for most people um
because like over over time like you
unintentionally build an echo chamber
like whether you mean to or not so uh
yeah if if you ever see that dynamic and
play on social media just just kind of
keep that in mind uh and if you're
listening to this and you're like an
influencer with a sizable audience and
you
ever start kind of like feeling this
dynamic taking place uh following advice
you give within your audience um yeah
also keep this in mind and try to be a
bit more circumspect about it
good advice yeah
all right uh i want to drop a little bit
of
of the good stuff here some some science
breaking out of more of the applied
anecdotal realm i do want to briefly
touch on one topic that is going to
specifically dive into some research
i briefly want to i'm going to address
like half of a q a
so one of the things that comes up all
the time in q and a's
is basically uh
hey i'm going to diet and i don't want
to lose lean mass and i don't want to
lose strength what should i do and i
think that um
i think we've covered the nutrition side
of that pretty extensively
over the years of articles and and
podcasting
if you go to stronger strongerby
science.com
diet there's a very comprehensive look
into it but the basics uh on the
nutrition side are pretty
straightforward um you want to retain
lean mass you want to retain your
performance to the best of your ability
certainly you want to make sure you're
eating enough protein spread across you
know somewhere between three to six
servings per day ideally
you don't want to go too fast with your
weight loss you know somewhere between
0.25 to 1 of body weight per week uh and
the
the leaner or the more advanced you are
as a lifter or the more concerned you
are about lean mass losses the more you
would err toward a slower rate of weight
loss so one percent of body weight per
week could be totally fine for lean mass
retention if you've got plenty of body
fat to lose you know you're you're kind
of beginner to intermediate with your
lifting eating plenty of protein if you
are
you know
elite natural bodybuilder absolutely
shredded toward the end of your prep you
do not want to be losing one percent of
body weight per week that is very likely
to start getting into a range that's a
little bit too quick based on the
context
so that's the nutrition and rate of
weight loss side which is fairly
straightforward
you know garth and colleagues in 2011.
that's one of the classic papers
demonstrating how going a little bit too
fast with your weight loss
in really high level athletes can start
to impair
uh you know changes in body composition
changes in performance
when it comes to training
this is something we've talked about on
the podcast before
uh and i want to frame it as a very
specific problem statement because this
is how a lot of people approach it
so
i'm not cutting yet you know i'm about
as strong as i've ever been i'm
performing well fueling my workouts
everything's going well congrats dude
yeah thank you
and right now for some random exercise
i'm able to do four sets of eight with
about 200 pounds
uh and you know
you know that might fluctuate day to day
it might be a slight positive uh you
know trajectory because i'm doing
progressive overload and not everyone
can do delt raises with that much weight
but eric's a freak so exactly this is
just his personal example dude speaking
of that i saw a video on instagram the
other day have you ever seen bo
jackson's first hit in the major leagues
no
dude
he hits a crisp chopper
to the gap between first and second base
the second baseman fields it cleanly
beau runs it out whoo
it's it's just a freaking chopper to the
second baseman no one's like fumbling to
cover the base he just runs out
a hard hit to the second baseman that's
ridiculous an infield hit bo knows
baseball i i thought it was a doctored
video honestly i checked uh but anyway
so i'm able to do four by eight with 200
pounds
as this cut progresses
most likely there's going to be a point
where i can no longer do four sets of
eight with 200 pounds uh depending on
how aggressive the cut is and how much
ground i'm trying to cover but i might
get to a point where now if i'm using
200 pounds i'm only able to do
eight and then six and then five and
five you know instead of eight eight
eight eight
so a lot of people within that problem
statement say
what what's my best strategy here should
i
for example reduce set volume am i
trying to do too many sets in my
workouts and it's you know because i
have lower recovery capacity should i
keep the load that i'm using and instead
of trying to do sets of eight maybe i'm
trying to do sets of six you know
so should i be or should i keep trying
to do four sets of eight with the same
relative difficulty and drop the load so
instead of doing 4x8 with 200 now i'm
doing it with 185 and it's going okay
so the question is what do i do here
to
most effectively
preserve my strength or preserve my fat
free mass and specifically with this i
want to talk about fat free mass
so
should i be dropping the rep range a
little bit should i be dropping some set
volume should i be dropping the load to
make this a little bit more feasible uh
this is a question we've talked about
before and
uh we've mentioned how we're we're both
kind of a bit surprised that there's
simply not direct research on this that
we're aware of yeah that that really
really specifically shows if you're
cutting
here is the blueprint blueprint for
managing your training variables to best
retain
muscle mass or fat free mass like to our
knowledge that doesn't exist yeah we
don't even have
one blueprint and in other fields they
have the blueprint two the blueprint
three perfect we're we're really behind
in this area um so yeah we've talked
about this before on the show we've said
listen if you want an evidence-based
statement i don't have much for you if
you want kind of a practical applied
statement that involves some speculation
you know my personal approach in this
situation is i
generally as a cut starts getting really
brutal i start to reduce my repetition
ranges a little bit and i start to cut
my set volume a little bit especially
for some of the ancillary kind of uh
you know my assistance exercises or my
auxiliary exercises
uh because what i notice is first of all
you start getting like let's say the the
the experience i'm drawing on here is
deep into a contest prep
uh i don't have the glycogen to give you
a good set of i certainly not to give
you four good sets of 12. right it's not
there i'm cutting my carbs are low it's
just gone
and so in that context i like to drop my
rep ranges so that i can
at least lean harder on my phospho
creatine system and my glaring lack of
glycogen won't become quite as apparent
in my performance of my exercises
so i like to
make my rep ranges a little bit more
compatible with the energy systems that
i can still kind of reliably lean on
i drop my set volume because like if
you've ever had a high volume program
you start to know when you're getting
into what some people would colloquially
call junk volume where at a certain
point you're like why am i still in the
gym like this is this is kind of
nonsense what i'm doing here yeah when
you're deep into prep you reach that
point pretty early in a workout if you
try to maintain the same number of
exercises and sets and yeah if you keep
everything the same
that point where you start to say am i
actually doing anything here it comes a
lot earlier in the workout so for that
reason i like to drop my set volume a
little bit so that i'm
being as efficient as i can with really
high quality effort in the gym
and
there is some evidence to suggest uh
that when it comes to change to gains in
fat free mass and muscle mass uh you
know the volume it took to build that
muscle
may not necessarily be as much as it
takes to maintain that muscle uh you
know there there have been
fairly long term longitudinal trials
where they have a muscle building phase
where they gain some muscle with a
relatively higher volume program and
they can actually maintain it pretty
effectively when they cut that volume
down a little bit as long as intensity
remains high so for that cluster of
reasons
my general approach would which i would
not say is like conclusively the best
way to do it but the way that i find
most favorable
is to
trim my repetition ranges a little bit
and cut my set volume a little bit
especially for some of the less critical
exercises in my program but one of the
reasons i wanted to address this topic
is because there is recently a
systematic review by roth and colleagues
and it's called lean mass sparing and
resistance trained athletes during
caloric restriction the role of
resistance training volume
and one of the reasons i wanted to
get into this
is because
it kind of
takes the form of a bit of a systematic
review so uh they mentioned that they
did like a systematic literature search
uh and kind of dive into this topic in a
general sense
and i don't want it to seem like i'm
being super critical of the paper right
so
in terms of just like writing a review
paper
they bring up some interesting
perspectives they discuss it in a
thorough way they talk about some
mechanisms
they present a perspective that isn't
100 compatible with the perspective that
i just shared but that's okay
uh you know like i said it when there's
a lack of direct evidence there are
going to be conflicting opinions that
are
in many cases all justifiable you know
as long as they're based on something
they can be justified the reason i
wanted to bring up this paper though is
it does kind of take the form of a
systematic review and i think a lot of
people might take the conclusion from it
and say oh damn this is high level
evidence on the hierarchy of evidence so
the hierarchy of evidence you know
we've talked about it before i believe
on the podcast but it's basically a way
of organizing different types of
observations and published research and
saying which of these carries more
weight
which of these has higher quality of
evidence and lower risk of bias and so
you start with like kind of an editorial
or a narrative review which is just
somebody who's writing a paper and
saying i've got some [ __ ] i want to say
about this topic and i'm going to say it
and that's pretty much the entire set of
guardrails for a narrative review yeah
you know you just write some stuff if
the reviewers like it hey that's science
baby i'm going to throw out a hot take
that i've mentioned on the podcast
before and i still stand by it a
narrative review is a blog post
yes yeah
but
you know that that two people signed off
on and in a blog that's very hard to
edit correct yeah
not easy to make a quick update sorry i
had a typo yeah that'll be fixed in nine
months yeah
and i'll have to issue a big apology
yeah and uh the the fact that you made a
typo will will forever be in the aratum
section of your cv so
maybe there are structural incentives
against ever making corrections but yeah
whatever so we've got those and then
we've got mechanistic studies maybe in
rodents and a you know a cell culture
where we unders we start to understand
how stuff works but it may not
generalize to a person a living human
being also sorry just to make clear i
don't want to make it sound like i'm
throwing shade at narrative reviews
because i'm not throwing shade at blog
posts i'm a blogger i think vlogs can be
good i just think that uh
yeah
once you once you start getting into the
the realm of narrative reviews the
uh presumed bright line
between published research and
blogging gets it's very fuzzy
uh yeah but yeah there are a lot of
tremendously valuable narrative reviews
uh and i i don't i don't want to make it
sound like i don't think there are
yeah it's yeah we've both been in the
situation where we we like write a blog
post and someone's like hey why don't
you submit this to a journal so it
actually matters and counts and you're
like
i mean i've i've published narrative
reviews i would have written this the
same way they just would have told me to
like write in a more passive tone yeah
this is this is what the article would
have been and it would have gotten 120th
as many reads exactly yeah but anyway so
we've got those narrative reviews then
we've got mechanistic studies and then
case studies or case reports moving up
to cross-sectional studies up to case
control studies into cohort studies and
then into randomized controlled trials
where we're actually able to
experimentally control some of these
variables and do you know really well
controlled interventions where we can
start making some pretty nice claims
about causation with a decent level of
confidence and then at the top of this
hierarchy that's where we start to find
systematic reviews and meta-analyses of
randomized controlled trials they are at
the top of the hierarchy which is which
suggests they have the highest quality
of evidence and the lowest risk of bias
but
it's really important to recognize that
this
uh
hierarchy of evidence is basically a
heuristic you know it's it's a general
indicator of how we make sense of
different types of research but it does
not mean
that the first time
a systematic review
that puts forward a conclusion comes out
like oh well glad we solved that now
we've answered it you know so my my
concern is that since
this recent paper seems kind of like a
systematic review and has a systematic
literature search and study coding and
all that stuff that people are going to
say oh damn i guess we answered this
question that's great uh because i think
when we call something a systematic
review it assigns a particular weight to
it
that we have to be very cautious about
when we're interpreting so uh
for example um i was looking at a paper
by garg and colleagues and this was from
a a study on er from a journal that's
focused on renal like kidney research
and a little clip that i saw in there
was
they're talking about systematic reviews
being good but they also mentioned
however
important methodologic flaws of
systematic reviews uh have been well
described and for example of the 86
renal systematic reviews published in
2005 58 had important methodologic flaws
so
they are systematic review so you look
at the title you look at the abstract
and say oh damn this is the highest
level of evidence
but but that does not mean that you just
look for the closest systematic review
look for the conclusion and that's that
you've got your answer uh so
they did provide which i thought was
really helpful
a checklist for questions to ask when
you're assessing the quality of a
systematic review
one was the review conducted according
to a pre-specified protocol
two was the question focused and well
formulated the research question
three were the right types of studies
eligible for the review
four was the method of identifying all
relevant information information
comprehensive
so for example is it likely that they
missed some relevant studies or that
you know perhaps they didn't consider
publication bias number five was the
data abstraction from each study
appropriate uh were the methods used in
each individual study appraised and
actually you know considered in the
synthesis of this information uh and
then number six along those lines was
the information synthesized and
summarized appropriately uh and and was
it even reasonable to kind of lump these
things together in the first place
whether that's
qualitative or quantitative in terms of
how this evidence is lumped together and
synthesized to form conclusions so you
might be wondering eric why are we
digging into the text of a renal journal
what the hell are we talking about here
well i'm i'm not gonna lie as the
co-host i have forgotten what the mean
the main topic exactly this segment is
already
yes so
again we're talking about how am i
supposed to train in order to retain
lean mastery
yes and my concern is that people will
see this paper and say oh that's a
systematic review that settles that
that's the highest level of evidence
we're all good it's critically important
to recognize that this is a systematic
review
of zero randomized controlled trials
that directly answer that question yeah
so despite the fact that you say oh
systematic review high level evidence a
systematic review can only provide
informative answers
when the studies involved directly uh
you know provide evidence related to
that research question yeah in theory uh
you know the the some
the sum of the systematic review is at
least
related to the whole of its parts where
you know if there's a lot of high
quality evidence in an area a systematic
review that you know
one makes the readers aware of all of
the evidence in the area and does a
really good job synthesizing it can add
a tremendous amount of value but you
know if there
if there's not that
a systematic review may be able to add
value to
effectively nothing but the
the upper limits of of the additive
value it can provide uh is
necessarily constrained yeah
so uh
the the reason i bring all this stuff up
is
the topic at hand of you know how should
i be adjusting these training variables
during cutting to preserve lean mass has
not really been directly studied and i
think the researchers
like i said they wrote a nice paper they
went into a lot of interesting topics
presented the evidence well
but this is not in the strictest terms a
systematic review investigating that
question
uh because there aren't
the underlying data do not directly
address that question you could
theoretically get at it indirectly if
you could look at this group of studies
from the review and say yeah the only
real major thing differentiating these
studies is the way that they adjusted
these particular uh training variables
in this case training volume so you'd
have to have some degree of confidence
that there are not
major confounding factors other
important factors from these studies
that are influencing the conclusions
drawn
so in this case
my primary
concerns about whether or not this paper
directly addresses the question is
the research question itself was a
little bit ambiguous they talked a lot
about
volume as a mechanism of preserving lean
mass
but there were some studies looking at
high volume versus low volume programs
and other studies looking at
increasing volume over time versus
decreasing volume over time so the
amount of absolute volume versus
relative change in volume there are kind
of these dueling research questions that
were intermingled a little bit
some of the terms such as reducing and
increasing training volume weren't
really
defined very explicitly in quantifiable
terms which made categorizing them a
little bit difficult
and so for for example in one instance
uh
a paper was
categorized as a volume reduction study
it had two training blocks and training
volume went up over time from block one
to block two but it was considered a
volume reduction study because there was
a deload between the blocks and they
said because volume went down in the
d-load
that is a volume reduction program even
though overall volume did go up over
time
um there was a mixture of studies with
participants of different training
status um so for example
looking at oh and just the magnitude of
weight loss changed a lot so in some
cases they were make they were
hoping to make inferences about how
training volume impacts the loss of lean
mass while cutting but they're comparing
a very modest amount of weight loss in
relatively untrained folks or or you
know moderately trained folks versus
a case study of a bodybuilder cutting
for a show getting shredded yeah so
we're talking about losing a couple
kilograms when you've got plenty of
kilograms to lose versus getting
absolutely shredded and fat-free mass
loss and contest prep is
is the rule not the exception when we
look at the case studies on male uh
bodybuilders cutting for shows drug
tested fat-free mass losses are usually
observed and
often quite substantial
another example is you know looking at
short-term changes in fat free mass with
a mixture of keto studies and non-keto
studies
obviously based on the the randomized
controlled trials with keto studies
you're gonna expect in the first few
weeks that we have an initial drop in
fat free mass that is largely due to a
drop in water and glycogen most likely
yeah um so
all of that is to say
i think uh i wanted to get out ahead of
the idea that
this is now a settled question because
there's a systematic review on it i'm
not trying to uh you know diminish the
effort of the authors because like i
said i think
the paper as a narrative review very
much accomplishes what a narrative
review would want to do it says hey
here's this question we don't have
direct evidence let's try to piece
together some related studies and see if
we can draw some inferences for now and
basically generate hypotheses so i think
it was an excellent paper for generating
hypotheses but i think it it does lend
itself to some misinterpretation
because it is kind of framed as a
systematic review so getting back to it
you know i kind of mentioned how i like
to approach training when i'm cutting
that is
uh a loosely evidence informed
speculative approach you know i i think
it's it's rooted in ideas that come from
evidence but i can't call it an
evidence-based statement if that makes
sense yeah um but yeah so
i would encourage people to reserve
judgment and not just say well there's a
systematic review looks like the answer
uh is is clear now
i don't think that's the case but i do
appreciate and commend the authors for
if nothing else bringing awareness to
the fact like there is no direct
research on this and it is an extremely
applicable question so my my hope is
that researchers are going to see this
and say hey
we ought to do a randomized controlled
trial and start getting to the bottom of
this yeah
all right uh what do you got to close
out the show here do you want to do your
random segment yeah yeah
so this is a segment that uh
you know wouldn't fit under any of the
general classifications we use on the
show it's certainly not a research
review not a research roundup not really
a coach's corner so yeah just random
segments uh we'll call this the shout
out segments well this um this is a
we're revisiting a segment that we tried
and swiftly abandoned it's not really
yeah yeah so we used to have a segment
called on the rise where oh yeah where i
i would ask people to uh
you know let me know if there were uh
people coming up on social media who
maybe weren't getting as much attention
as they deserved uh
and to send those people in and i check
out their content and if it was good
shout them out um
that that was abandoned for
a couple reasons one was that there was
very little audience participation um
people didn't send in as many folks as i
i expected them to uh
two there there were very clear uh
campaigns that occurred where
you know someone who listens to our
podcast would tell their audience like
oh yeah yeah suggest me um
and like some of those people were fine
some of them i was like uh
why do you listen to our podcast
and uh then the third and probably most
important factor is i'm very lazy uh and
i i so one of the issues i ran into
early on was i was like um well how much
of this person's content do i need to
review because if it's like
five like the five most recent posts
like i can do that but you know if
someone maybe had like
a real stinker like not even that far
back like 15 posts back or something
you'd be like well um
i don't know if i want to go this route
and i'll tell you the thing that really
killed it uh what was co-fit
because
a lot of people who uh
were giving good advice in the fitness
realm were giving more questionable
advice in other contexts and i was like
yep i'm
yeah i'm shelving this segment the
fitness and virology
sectors kind of merge there for a minute
yeah so uh
you know and one of the things that
like kind of what you're alluding to
with one of those points is like when
you
like i i'm i have certainly no
reservations about saying like oh man
look at this great article this is a
great article everyone should read this
article check out this video this is
very nice but when you're kind of
recommending a person a person yeah it's
like
it's like uh could be
perceived as essentially a blank check
yeah and like it's like yeah i'm sure
that they've never said anything that's
terrible they've never had content that
is like just
indefensibly incorrect you know now now
that you mentioned that memories are
flooding back to me about
how that segment went and i remember i
started giving all of those caveats and
i fear that it came across as like wow
this person's fitness stuff is decent
but they're probably a shitty person
yeah assorted history
but yeah it was just like i mean i
basically had to say this person seems
to have good fitness content but i can't
vouch for them as a person which like
is completely honest uh but also it
implies that it's like oh man yeah and
like i wasn't trying to imply that but i
i don't know how to state that in a way
that wouldn't potentially carry that
implication
um
so yeah yeah it got away from that
segment so this this is not a return of
on the rise because all of these people
are already uh they have risen yeah
they're they're well established but um
yeah i wanted to give some shout outs to
people who
are out there on social media uh doing
great work um
and
like like putting out good good
information uh in a c awash with
disinformation and misinformation um who
i think that our audience doesn't have a
ton of overlap with so you know like i
think that our audience has quite a bit
of overlap with like eric helms and
omar's audience and the iron culture
podcast audience uh the barbell medicine
audience i think we have a lot of
overlap with like andy morgan's audience
um
but there there are
uh people who i follow who
i don't see mentioned as frequently in
kind of stronger by science groups and
channels um
who uh yeah i think more of you guys
should probably be following and so the
person i'm going to lead off with and
what actually inspired this uh this
segment is in the most recent q a
threads someone asked what we thought
about ben patrick who is also known on
instagram as knees over toes guy
like does he put out good information or
is he a fraud
and i was like ah you know what guy
actually puts out solid solid
information i don't want to just talk
about him so let's let's just kind of
make a segment out of this
but yeah so i'll i'll start with him ben
patrick otherwise known as knees over
toes guy
uh and i think that he's a bit
controversial
not due to the information he presents
but due to the way that he presents it
so i i do think that he
tends to be a bit hyperbolic in his
presentation he'll say like oh yeah like
here here's this approach to
uh training to improve knee health and
resiliency and this is
um
you know uh uh super revolutionary stuff
no one else is doing this um and that's
kind of like the selling point like
here's this cutting-edge [ __ ] that i'm
on and no one else is um
and that that might be like slightly
overstating how hyperbolic he is but
that's like kind of the tone um
and like that bit isn't true like most
of the stuff he's recommending
is just
good solid evidence-based info that uh
physical therapists and rehab
professionals have been using for years
but he he packages it and presents it in
a way
that is
interesting engaging and informative for
the general public
who
may otherwise
not want to do some of that stuff
because you know like with
you know when it comes to kind of like
rehab exercises
unless you are unless you have some sort
of serious injury or like major
pre-existing issue um it's easy to look
at that stuff and be like ah no like
that's boring i just want to go squat
heavy and so it's it's sometimes hard to
convince people to do things that would
be good for them and i think that he's
very good at that so he's
uh he's putting out solid information uh
in a way that maybe is a bit hyperbolic
but the quality of the information and
the advice he gives is is generally
quite high
um so yeah uh he he is certainly worth a
follow
um
moving on the next person i'd recommend
is ben carpenter so um
he he talks about all sorts of subjects
but i think what he's probably most well
known for
is uh calling out and debunking bad
information that's going around social
media and there are
there are a lot of people who do that
but i think that ben is particularly
good at it um
both in terms of
making his points in in in a concise and
informative way
uh and in a way that's that's often
quite funny um so you know if if that's
something that interests you uh he is a
very solid follow
um moving on i mentioned i think that
our audience has quite a bit of overlap
with barbell medicine person i'm gonna
recommend is now a barbell medicine
coach but i started following her when
she was not so i still think of her as
kind of her own thing and you know
not to imply that if you coach for a
company you are now just that company
you've been absorbed into the borg uh
but yeah whatever i'm just rambling at
this point clear as i yeah we let our
coaches have interests we let them spend
time with their families yeah they don't
just like become uh you know
part of the company they still function
independently to some extent yeah yeah
um but yeah i know so claire zai is a
very solid follow uh on social media
instagram particularly like i said she's
she's a coach for barbell medicine these
days and uh she puts out really good in
information just about uh training in
general like she tends to be pretty
focused on that uh and also female
specific issues around uh strength
training so
a lot of stuff about the menstrual cycle
in particular
so she's a very very solid follow
and last but certainly not least
emma story gordon who
um
i don't know i think that our spheres
used to overlap quite a bit more and and
now they don't um but yeah she's she's a
tremendous follow uh
mostly
on instagram giving weight loss advice
and there are plenty of people on
instagram giving weight loss advice but
i think that she's particularly good at
it because
most of the information she gives is
very evidence-based and and practical
without being off-puttingly sciency and
by that i mean
i recognize that this podcast for
probably not this episode of this
podcast but by and large this podcast
is is probably off-puttingly sciency for
some non-trivial percentage of people um
so you know if if you
wanted to
uh recommend folks for advice to
you know someone in your family who
doesn't know anything about resistance
training it's like ah you know follow
these people for for good practical
advice maybe you wouldn't recommend our
podcast because you're like yeah these
these guys uh
the the stuff they're saying might like
go over people's heads so
what emma's really good at is is she's
good at giving
uh uh
like science-based recommendations and
advice
in a way that
won't go over people's heads um
and and yeah so it's it's very it's very
practical and um
also
uh she tends to present things in a way
that is
kind of more empathetic and less
judgmental than you will often see
from people who
do focus a lot on giving weight loss
advice um
so yeah she's she is a very solid follow
as well would would strongly recommend
so when you say that she's not
off-puttingly sciency does that mean she
will not read you six points on how to
appraise a systematic review uh
yeah probably so
um but yeah i mean like she she knows
her stuff like she
yeah like yeah there there's
there's different forms of science
communication and she
definitely does a different form of
scientific communication than we do um
one might say better
you know
one might one might
that's okay yeah
um all right so
that's a great list hopefully people
will check them out what do you have to
play us out
yeah so uh to play us out has recently
just turned into a meteor a meteor
review and recommendation segment
but i got another good one this week and
that is a hulu show called under the
banner of heaven
it is based on a i believe 2003 john
krakauer book by the same name
and uh the book is about uh some murders
that took place in
the mormon community and also
delving into
um
you know some of maybe the less talked
about
aspects of the history of mormonism and
the show is is very much following kind
of the same the same line uh it's it's
starring andrew garfield who does a
tremendous job it's it's a very well
acted show i think it's
i think it's gonna be six episodes maybe
and we're through episode three or four
um so far it's really good i'm less
concerned about this show sticking the
landing um because
i know it comes from a book and you know
they don't have to worry about how it's
going to wrap up because like it's a
real story um
and also i want to make clear with this
recommendation um
you know i i got i got nothing but love
for most mormons uh i don't like that
it's
it's a piece of media that could be
interpreted as just critical of
mormonism in and of itself we're not out
here on this podcast trying to start
religious conflict um
you know i think most mormons very cool
it's just a good piece of media
and i also imagine most mormons would
probably not be fans of
the
particular branch of mormonism that is
really put under the the microscope uh
in this particular piece of media but
anyway it's a great show called under
the banner of heaven and uh
that sounds good to you you should check
it
out i know i don't want to
i know you're going to be upset i don't
have a
show recommendation this week damn i'm
i'm shocked i normally do but no you
don't this week i'm stumped
no i
i i watch a new show you know we've
discussed it before once every several
years so i'm i'm kind of planning my
next move and waiting for the right time
uh but but i have no idea what the next
one's gonna be
um
you know what i do have an idea of what
the next episode we're going to release
which is going to be one week from today
what a segway it's a great segue as
always thank you for listening and we
will see you next time
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode of the stronger by science
podcast
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you